>> Hi. Hello everyone.
Hi I'm [inaudible] .
I'm a researcher here at the LTC.
I'm their [inaudible] and
I'm going to be chairing
the session this afternoon.
We're going to have
three awesome talks
and then we're
going to start with
Kristen and she's
going to be talking
about Adverbial Clausal Modifiers
in the LinGO Grammar Matrix.
So take it away.
>> Okay. Hi, today
I'll be presenting
an extension to
the LinGO Grammar matrix that
will allow for
the automatic production of
precision grammars that
accommodate adverbial
clausal modifiers.
So this is a little bit
less of an NLP talk,
so I'm going to start by
giving you a background
on precision grammars and
the grammar matrix in particular,
and then I'll
discuss the topology
of clausal modifiers in
the world languages,
introduce you briefly to
our syntactic analysis
and then go through
our development of the library
and our evaluation
and error analysis.
So precision grammars are
bi-directional grammars that
parse and generate sentences,
but their strength
is that they produce
very precise syntactic and
semantic representations.
In our case, the syntactic
representations are in
the HPSG formalism and
the semantics are using
minimal recursion semantics.
The most important thing
about these grammars is that
they prioritize precision meaning
we care about what
proportion of our parses are
the right parse rather
than being as concerned
with our overall coverage.
Uses for these grammars
include building grammars
for languages where
we don't necessarily have
enough data for
traditional NLP methods,
but we do have
linguistic information
that we can utilize.
Linguists use these grammars
for hypothesis testing,
checking their analyses over
a corpus and these
are also useful
for finding out what's
actually in your corpus.
When you run your corpus
through one of these grammars,
you might find a phenomenon
that you didn't realize was there
or you might actually find
some inconsistencies either in
your data or in your annotation.
However, these grammars are
very expensive and time
consuming to create.
So, the LinGO Grammar Matrix is
a starter kit for creating
the HPSG grammars.
Basically it elicits
information from the user about
the language and then
produces grammars from that.
So a quick example.
This is the word order page on
the customization screen and
it asks the user
what's the basic word
order of the language;
is the subject verb object,
subject object verb and so forth?
Do the determiners come
before or after the noun?
Do auxiliaries come before or
after their verbal complements?
Then based on the user's
input on this page
and analyses developed based
on the typological literature,
a precision grammar is
output that can now
accommodate that phenomenon.
Right now the grammar
matrix includes
a wide variety of phenomenon
including word order morphology,
tense and aspect, but
previously it did
not accommodate subordinate
clauses of any kind.
So today we're
presenting a library
for adverbial clausal modifiers.
These are your
subordinate clauses
that present
information like time,
purpose, your basic while
because type clauses.
In the world's languages
these manifest in
a number of ways but follow
three basic patterns.
Typically clausal
modifiers are marked by
a free subordinating
morpheme and I'll
just use the word
subordinator moving forward.
This is a word like win or
tow in the Japanese
example at the top.
I can point to that.
Another pattern is
subordinator pairs
and we see these very
robustly in Mandarin.
Such as the yinwei so ui pair,
where you have this
because subordinator in
the subordinate clause,
but then in the matrix
clause you have
to have this additional adverb.
These are also really
common in if-then clauses
cross-linguistically
and it's easier
to think of an English example.
Finally, sometimes
subordinate clauses
are marked just with
verbal morphology.
So the purposive suffix right
here in this example from
Louise signo marks that
subordinate clause
as a purposive clause.
In addition to
these basic patterns,
we also see a very wide range
of variation within
these clauses and
any given language will
probably be marked by
a handful of different strategies
that utilize
these characteristics.
So these include the position of
the clausal modifier whether it's
before or after the main clause,
whether or not there's a pair,
whether there's
additional verbal morphology,
so you might have
a subordinator and then also a
non-finite verb in the
subordinate clause.
Sometimes the clause
is nominalized
or the subject is shared,
so it's unexpressed in
the subordinate clause but
expressed in the main clause.
So this is an example like;
I went to the store to buy bread,
where I is the subject of
both clauses but unexpressed
in the purposive clause.
So in order to
account for the space and
analyze this within
the grammar matrix,
we introduce two lexical types
and two unary rules.
And abstracting away from
the nitty-gritty HPSG
on this slide,
basically what we've
done is we've created
four supertypes that account
for the basics of
each strategy whether
it's a subordinator or
morphological subordination.
Then onto the supertypes,
we can add new features
in the subtypes.
So to account for
all of these characteristics
on this slide,
we add feature
definitions that we
can put into the subtypes
for each subordinate
clause strategy.
So for example, we use
the posttype feature,
which is just a Boolean feature
to constrain whether
the clausal modifier goes
before or after the main clause.
And if it's free to
go in either place,
then really that underspecified.
In our development, we use
two sets of development data.
Sorry about that.
A quick example of how we
map those features onto
the customization page for
the user is that we use
an iterator that allows
a user to define as many clausal
modifier strategies as they want.
So they can have the purpose
of strategy that just
uses the drop subject in the
non-finite and to buy bread,
and they can use
a different strategy
for a because clause
which is marked by
a subordinator and they're
free to fill in as many
strategies as they need.
So when developing, we use
two sets of development data.
Our first stage is
pseudo languages.
These are languages with
a minimal lexicon that are
designed to capture
the typological space.
So we'll just use
a simple language
where the nouns are
called noun one,
noun two and the verbs are
called verb one, verb two.
Then we captured
the typological space as best we
can by pairing each subordinator
type with each feature.
So going back to
the previous slide,
we have all of these
feature values that are
possible on
the subordinator types
and we'll test this add
position subordinator
lexical type
with one of the post
add features.
But if we were to actually
test all of them,
we'd have a 1008 tests languages
and that would be really
cumbersome because these aren't
just test instances these
are full languages.
So, the end of this stage,
we expect four coverage.
We should be able to capture
the typological space by
accounting for every possible
combination of features.
However, we don't test
each feature value,
just every feature type.
After that, our second
development set
is illustrative languages,
and at this point we actually
get involved with
natural language.
It's a bit messier
because we're testing
interactions that actually
occur in real languages,
such as subject dropping
in the language,
various word order patterns,
and these interacting phenomena
can cause complications
that weren't
previously tested in the
pseudo language evaluation
or pseudo language testing.
So, we used four
real languages that
were selected specifically to
illustrate a
particular phenomena.
So, we use Mandarin to illustrate
the subordinator pair that
I've discussed previously.
Rukai requires that subordinate
clauses be nominalized.
German is a v2 language,
verb second language,
that requires verb
final word order
and subordinate clauses,
so we tested that.
Then, Wambaya is
a language that marks
its subordinate clauses
morphologically,
we tested that as well.
Now at this stage,
we discovered one phenomena
that's not captured
in our library,
and probably shouldn't be,
and this is that subordinate
clauses actually have
a different case frame on
the objects in those clauses,
so a nominative accusative
language will actually
have dative case in the
subordinate clause.
So, we decided that
this should actually
be treated separately as
a valence change in operation in
another library that we
set aside for future work.
So, we don't expect
four coverage here,
as those examples aren't
expected to parse.
So, finally, move
on to evaluation,
and at this stage we test
the typological diversity and
reliability of our system
by testing on five
held out languages.
This is not just held out data,
but these are languages
that we did not
consider at all
during development.
The way we construct
our test suites and
grammars is by reading
the descriptive grammars
written by field linguists that
have a lot of very detailed data
and prose descriptions,
and we develop
our test suites from that.
These languages were
selected in a random manner,
but required to be genetically
and geographically diverse.
So, if I pulled
two Indo-European languages
off the shelf,
I would put them back
until we represent five distinct
language families here.
We achieved 88
percent coverage and
two percent over-generation
at this point.
That two percent
over-generation comes from
just one ungrammatical
example parsing,
and that really shows
our fidelity to precision here.
As for our error analysis,
this actually tells
us quite a bit about
the library and about the
typology of clausal modifiers.
So, I've broken this
into two categories,
In Scope phenomena and
Out of Scope phenomena.
We had one sentence
fell to parse in
Moseten due to a constraint
in the supertype that
shouldn't have been there,
should have been
added in the subtype,
so that's a bug and it's fixed.
Next, we found a bug in the
nominalized clauses library,
where nominalized clauses had
a special head subject rule
to allow for that attachment,
but did not account
for subject dropping.
Meaning, if a nominalized
clause did not have
an overt subject,
that's going to parse,
and it turns out that
it's possible in Basque,
so we created a rule
and inserted that into
the grammar to make
sure that that sentence
would parse if
that rule was there.
Next we get to Out
of Scope Phenomena,
and this is really
the interesting part
of the error analysis,
because we see what didn't
come up in the
typological literature
that turns out is out there
in the world's languages.
Our first error came from
the same case change issue
that we saw in Wambaya,
and so I have an
example for you here.
In this language,
third-person subjects are
marked with accusative
case instead of
nominative case in the
subordinate clause,
and so you see that here.
So, this wasn't accounted for,
and we had one sentence
that is grammatical
fail to parse,
and then one ungrammatical
sentence parse,
and that's what led to
our two percent over-generation.
The next thing we
found in Ma'di is
that subordinators actually
can attach to a verb.
So, in the typological
literature,
we saw the subordinators
attaching either
to the sentence on
the outside of the clause or to
the verb phrase intervening
between a subject and verb.
But we never saw it intervening
between the verb and its object.
In fact, in Ma'di,
it's possible in the sentence,
"If Opi brings beer, he
should put it on the shelf."
'If' can intervene between
'bring' and 'beer'.
So, this is easy enough
to add now that we
know that it's possible
in the world's languages,
and that'll be part
of our future work.
Finally, we found in
Lavukaleve that the same pair,
adverb phenomena that we see in
phenomena or that you
see in Mandarin where
you have a subordinator in
the clausal modifier and
an adverb in the main clause,
can occur where you have
a morphologically marked
subordinate clause,
and you still need an adverb
and the main clause.
So, there was
only a brief description
of this in the prose
and one example.
So, what we would like to do is
some further investigation in
the typological literature,
as well as in that language
before adding
this functionality to
the library just to make sure.
So, what we've done today
is we'd introduced
a new library that now
accommodates one type of
subordinate clause in
the grammar matrix,
so that these precision grammars
can be automatically produced.
Are there any questions?
I don't know who's.
>> What do the
grammars look like,
is it like for
structure rules or explore?
>> Yeah. So, the question is what
do the grammars look like?
So, we're using the head-driven
phrase structure
grammar formalism,
and this is a lexically-driven
syntactic framework,
and we have a combination of
lexical entries and
phrase structure rules. Yeah.
>> What does that bring
you up to for how much
of English prose are
you able to parse now,
what rules are you still
missing and how do
you do all of it and
just some other languages
you don't do?
>> That's a great question.
So, the grammar matrix
actually grew out of the
English resource grammar,
which covers 96 percent of
well-edited English
text, maybe it's 94.
So that's a very large grammar.
We haven't actually
tested this on English,
like the grammar matrix
outputs on English,
we are still missing a
number of phenomena.
A library for clausal compliment
has just been added,
but there's still
more to be done.
We don't have relative clauses,
we don't have WH questions,
so still wouldn't be
quite close to there.
But that work has been done
on the individual language level.
Other questions?
Yes.
>> So, one question
about what is left to
do for any other world languages?
You just did the
adverbial clauses oris there
anything that's missing?
>> Yeah. In terms of phenomena
that are not yet in
the grammar matrix,
we're still missing quite a bit.
So, what I would recommend you
do is go to the grammar matrix
page and see what's there,
and then you should be able
to figure out what's not.
But there are lots
of new phenomena,
relative clauses, I think
it's a next direction.
Adverbs themselves,
not adverbial clauses,
but just adverbs haven't
been implemented yet.
Yeah.
Right.
>> If you can just give her
an applause. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Michael is going
to be talking about
SimpleQuestions Nearly Solved and
new unbounded in
baseline approach.
It's a joint work with
Luke Zettlemoyer.
Take it.
>> Hi, there. My name is
Michael and I'm
presenting as said,
SimpleQuestions
Nearly Solved, this was
undergraduate research that I
did at the Paul G. Allen School.
To give you first
a brief overview of my talk,
first we're going
to introduce you to
the widely used
SimpleQuestions benchmark,
and then we're going to go over
the contributions
this paper has made.
Onto that benchmark first,
talking about that we
actually found that there
is an upper bound
on this benchmark,
and then introducing
a simple baseline method
that actually get state
of the art results.
Then, we'll conclude
that we found
that through our analysis
our upper bound it's loose,
and that the SimpleQuestions
dataset is nearly solved.
So, first, some background,
what is a simple question?
So, for example, who
wrote Gulliver's Travels
is a simple question.
The reason it's a simple
questions because it has
one relation, one subject,
and a simple question
stands for a
single-relation, single-subject
factoid question.
Why are these questions
interesting to look at?
Well, they appear often online,
specifically Microsoft has them
a lot in their query logs,
we see them popping
up in Wiki answers,
and they're commonly used
that voice assistance.
Although they're
very commonly used.
The most popular and largest
benchmark by a magnitude,
the state of the art results
on it are only 77 percent.
Okay. So, a little bit
more background.
The SimpleQuestions benchmark is
the largest
SimpleQuestions dataset
of a 108 thousand examples.
Each example has a question that
is labeled of a subject,
relation, and object.
It has a back-end
Freebase knowledge graph,
which is just a store facts.
Then, bringing up an example
for that, for example,
here is the relation and this
is the Freebase relation
for who wrote in this context.
For Gulliver's Travels,
the Freebase object has
an MID in an alias
Gulliver's Travels.
Okay. So the first contribution's
introducing an upper bound.
So, the example and
what's really driving
this work is that there's
fundamental contradictions in
the SimpleQuestions dataset.
For example, who wrote
Gulliver's travels
is referring to
the TV miniseries,
Gulliver's Travels, while
name a character from
Gulliver's Travels is referring
to Gulliver's Travels book.
That shows that
the linguistic signal on
these questions does
not provide or provides
equal evidence for if being
any other miniseries or a book in
both cases, it's not clear.
Okay.
So, how do we quantify this
and get to an upper bound?
So reminder, this is the data
that we're dealing with.
So the first thing we do is
we take a look at the alias,
come up with the list of
all Gulliver's Travels
in Freebase.
Similarly, we take out
Gulliver's Travels from
the question and we create
an abstract relation.
In SimpleQuestions,
who wrote co-occurs
with book written by,
film written by, film story
by, and other relations.
We can take a cross product
of these and these
are all possible interpretations
of the question that
we looked at before,
though some of them
don't make sense.
For example, for
Gulliver's Travels of the book,
you wouldn't have
the relation film.
So we just do a filter on them on
which ones we actually
find in Freebase.
From that, we come up with a list
of multiple correct
interpretations of who wrote
Gulliver's Travels
for which we have
equal linguistic evidence for
each one of this being correct,
yet we only have one ground truth
for example which
is number three.
Okay. So our results,
we find that on
this widely used benchmark,
33.9 percent of
the questions have
multiple correct interpretations
and therefore unanswerable.
So, in computing the upper bound,
we find that not all subject
relations are equal.
For example, in this case,
we come up with the relation
film language but
we have an option
between two subjects.
This one right here comes up
four times in Freebase while
this one right here
comes up in one,
and that distribution allows
us to set in majority
upper bound.
So we've picked the subject
relations which happened most
often in Freebase and we find
that the best we can do,
if we follow that simple baseline
is 83.4 percent on this dataset,
which is quite close to
the 77 percent state of the art.
Okay. Then the
second contribution
is we're actually able
to get state of the art
whith just standard
methods with fine-tuning.
So our baseline model is going to
consist of two neural models.
The first one is going to be
Top-K Subject Recognition which
models the distribution of
spans condition on the question.
Secondly, we're going to have
a Relation Classification model
conditioned on the question
and span modeling relation.
So, to better understand those,
here's just an input and output.
So we want film story by to have
the large probability given
this input, same up here.
So, why might we consider Top-K?
Because the first predicted span
might not always be helpful,
it might not always
be in Freebase.
So we can do a little bit
better by just
filtering what is in
Freebase and what is not.
Some more details with
this standards CRF Tagger.
We use viterbi inference which is
standard with a CRF Tagger.
We use IO Tagging,
GloVe embeddings,
and Grid search for
hyperparameter optimization.
Similarly here, we use a BiLSTM
of batchnorm and softmax.
We use AMSGrad which is
the new version of Adam
published recently.
FastText and Hyperband for
hyperparameter optimization.
So the results.
So these are the past results,
a lot of research has
been done on this
and boards that all
introduce this paper,
or introduce this dataset.
One sec.
To give you a little bit
of history here,
the first work done on this was
primarily trying to do
an end-to-end method.
So looking at one model
that can both
do relation and subject
classification.
These next two,
more recent papers,
we're looking at baseline
approaches of two models
and then these last three papers
were all building
custom architectures with
three models at times,
for various reasons.
So then applying this
standard approach
in better understanding
the dataset with fine-tuning,
we're able to get 78.1 percent,
which is close to
our upper bound of 83.4 percent.
So finally, we want to
understand what is
the difference here.
What work is left to be done?
So in understanding this,
we first consider
our first contribution
and we allow for
all correct interpretations
to be correct,
and that is 13 percent
of our error,
to start with, then we
found there is
a little bit of noise.
Finally, for the remaining error,
we found out that there's
actually further ambiguity,
so our initial analysis
was very static.
So, if there's any small changes
in the sentence,
this doesn't catch, that
didn't catch that ambiguity.
So empirical analysis show
that upper bound is
actually loose due to
this further ambiguity.
We find that in
real model errors,
that most of the work
left on this dataset
is actually in
low short relations
where we have
less than ten examples.
So in concluding,
due to the first ambiguity
found and due to
the further ambiguity we found,
there's not much more than
four percent performance
left on this dataset, we believe.
Secondly, we believe that
simple questions task
is largely solved
and this is due to the fact that
the remaining errors are
mostly due to a lack of data,
which is interesting
a little bit.
Yeah. Alright. Thank you.
>> I guess we can take questions,
we have a lot of time.
>> Yeah, go ahead.
>> If the upper bound is that
or it sounds like there's
the good reason to say
maybe we shouldn't just
be returning the top
best answer, right?
Maybe it should actually be
the best two or three of this,
especially if this
is to used by user.
I understand why
you'd want the top
one to compared to other systems.
But, have you
considered maybe making
an argument to for share tasks,
like maybe we want
to look at the top
three best answers or
something like that.
>> Yeah. For future datasets,
it's definitely important
to acknowledge the issue
that sometimes
the top one answer,
there could be multiple
correct interpretations. Yeah.
>> I have one question
here. You mentioned
that you could have
trained this end-to-end,
the relation classifier
and the other classifier.
Can you elaborate on
why you didn't do that?
If you had done it,
would you have solved
some of the issues that
you were mentioning?
>> So, fundamentally,
the purpose or our work
was trying to be
baseline and standard.
So, to integrate both tagging and
classification in one model
requires more than baseline work.
So, this is just the paper
first setting the baseline on
this task before thinking
about more custom architectures.
>> Do you have any examples
that you can show us
today? Did you prepare any?
>> Of custom architectures?
>> Okay.
>> No.
>> We'd like to question some
errors that the model made.
>> I don't have.
>> It would have been easier for,
I think you showed a few earlier,
but that's fine. If you
don't have it, that's fine.
>> Okay. Are you talking
about these errors?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I can send
them to you later.
>> Yeah. No problem. It
would be nice for us to see
what kind of errors that you're
missing, false positives, maybe.
>> Yeah, okay.
>> I don't know why I'm
not getting it. Does this
mean this is not really
a perfect simple questions
archives because there are
multiple answers to the
questions that are listed there?
Should you fix the test set?
So, is this all simple questions?
>> It's already
all simple questions.
Just these simple questions tend
to contradict
themselves with regards
to which relation
they're looking at.
For example, if we're
talking about the book,
Gulliver's Travels, we might
ask what is the language
of Gulliver's Travels?
If we're talking about
the film Gulliver's Travels,
we might also ask what
is the language of
Gulliver's Travels?
It's not clear if you're
talking about the book
or film unless you integrate
more complexity into
that question or, yeah.
>> That's an ambiguous answer,
it's still a simple question?
>> Yeah. Simple question can
have an ambiguous. Yeah.
>> Okay. Let's thank
Michael again.
So, we have Yi from
[inaudible] , Yi Luan.
I guess you can introduce
[inaudible] for yourself.
Take it away. Thanks.
>> Hi everyone, I'm Yi.
I'm working with Mari and Hannah.
I'm going to present
our recent work about
Scientific Relation
Extraction with
selectively incorporated
concept embeddings.
So, the reason we
are doing this work is that there
are countless scientific papers
published each year and
the tools that can
manage those scientific
knowledge are in great demand.
So, the goal for
this research is that we want
to develop information
extraction tools
using NLP approaches that
can support
scientific literature.
So basically, we want to build
scientific knowledge graph
and also we want to
answer some specific
scientific search queries.
So for example, if
you ask the computer,
"Show me the methods for
Apollo speech tagging,"
then the computer can
give us a list of
recommendations of methods that
can solve the problem such
as [inaudible] and HMM.
There are basically
two major steps
towards the task of scientific
information extraction.
So, the first one is
scientific concept
extraction which
is first introduced
in SemEval 2017.
So, the task will be to
identify some scientific phrase
spans and also classify
the phrase span into
concept categories,
such as method,
task and material.
So, for example in this sentence,
Conditional Random Fields and
Named Entity Recognition will
be extracted and classified
as Method and Task.
But the focus of
this paper will be
doing the Scientific
Relation Extraction,
which is to classify
the relations
between the pairs of
scientific concepts.
So, for example,
in this sentence,
we want to know that the relation
between Conditional
Random Fields and Named
Entity Recognition
is that one concept
is used for the other one.
So, the task is that given
the candidate concept pairs,
we'll want to classify them
into scientific relation types.
So, we introduce
five asymmetric relations
which is Usage,
Result, Model,
Part_Of, and Topic,
and one symmetric relation
which is Comparison.
So, the dataset we use is
SemEval 2018 Task seven which has
500 annotated scientific
abstracts from [inaudible].
The main challenge of
this task is that,
the annotation is pretty hard
which require domain expertise.
So, this result seem
like we only have
limited training data.
So, the contribution of
this research is
that we introduce
state-of-the-art
Neural Relation Extraction Model
to scientific domain,
and also we propose a novel
concept selection layer to
the neural structure to
mitigate the data
scarcity problem.
We obtain the
state-of-the-art results in
SemEval 2018 Task seven.
So, this is the overall structure
of our Neural Relation
Extraction Model,
which has mainly four components.
So, first given, this
sequence of text,
we want to use a Token
Sequential Layer to represent,
to do our representation
for the sequence and then
the representation
will be fit into
a Concept Presentation Layer
and Dependency Sequence Layer.
Then those representations
will be fit into
the final Relation
Classification Layer
and give us the final output.
First, the Token
Sequence Layer consists
of bi-directional LSTM which
takes the input of [inaudible]
matting and some featuring mattings.
Then the Dependency
Sequential Layer
is based on this representation.
We pass the sentence using
some dependency parser
and then we extract
the shortest pass between
the two concepts.
Then we decompose the dependency
pass into two parts.
We first find that
the common ancestor between
the two concepts
that were used in
this case and then
based on the direction
of the relation,
we will model Forward Dependency
pass and Backward Dependency
pass which represents
both the concepts,
the dependency passed
between the concept and
the common ancestor., So,
we would fit in the head
word representation
of each concept
and the common ancestor
representation to
the Backward and
Forward Dependency pass.
Then we would use
the representation,
concatenate those tokens as
a final representation
for the relation.
Then we can output
the final result.
So, this dependency presentation
itself can already give
us pretty good result,
but something is missing in
this structure that is
the representation
for the concepts.
This can model the whole span
of the phrases.
A traditional way
of doing this is,
an example, Miwa and Bansal 2016,
which they automatically
learn a weight,
Alpha, for each of
the individual token
in the whole concept.
And then there was some over
all of the tokens within
the concept span.
The limitation of
this approach is that
without introducing any prior
knowledge of the concept,
the automatically learned
representation will
generalize poorly
in the test time.
So, in order to
solve that problem,
we propose a new approach,
which is concept selection.
So, we first construct
a concept dictionary using
the frequent concepts,
and then learn a [inaudible]
for each of those concepts.
And then give it a new concept,
where we'll look up through
the concept dictionary
and see if there
is exact match for that phrase.
So, if there is one exact
match for the phrase,
we will use the pressure
and embedding
directly as a concept embedding.
But if there isn't
an exact match,
where we decompose the phrase
into some sub n-grams,
so, for example here, here,
pronominal, say the candidate
is pronominal
anaphora resolution,
but there's no exact match
in the concept dictionary,
so we will decompose
the whole phrase into
bigrams and unigrams.
Then we look up those bigrams and
unigrams in the dictionary
and find some meshes.
So, here is the resulting
candidates that we could find,
which is anaphora resolution,
resolution, and anaphora.
Then we will use
these candidates together
with a dummy vector,
the empty, to construct
the vector of candidate sets.
And then, in order to learn
the final representation,
we need to selectively combine
all those representations.
So in that case, we use
attention mechanism
to learn weight
between each of these
embedding and the representation
in the sequential layer.
And then we will sum over
all the candidates to
get the final embedding.
In order to get
the prior phrase knowledge,
we would first extract
all the concepts in
large-scale scientific corpus
using state-of-the-art
scientific term extractor
proposed in 2017.
Then we use Word2vec to train
all the frequent
concepts and then
construct this concept
dictionary.
The dataset that we'll use
in this task is
SemEval 2018 Task seven,
which has three sub-tasks.
So the first subtask is
relation classification,
which we assume that
concept pairs and
relation directions are given,
so we need to choose between
the six defined relations.
The second task is
relation extraction,
where given all the concepts,
we need to identify if
the relation exists,
and this is the binary
classification task.
The third task is
relation extraction and
classification task.
So, we need first to extract
those relations and then
classify them into six relations
together with their directions.
So, the external dataset we
use to train
this concept embedding
is semantic scholar corpus,
which has 110K abstracts,
and the ACL Anthology
referenced corpus,
which has 22K full papers.
So, here is the results.
Our system got the best result
in subtask 2.1,
and we also do a good job
in other two tasks.
So, Team One data a little bit
better than this,
but they use
more supervised data.
We also perform
ablation studies by
removing some of the components
of the neural network.
So, we first remove
the dependency layer,
which we could see that
the F1 score decreased greatly,
and then we will move
this concept layer,
which also results in
a slightly worse F1 score.
We also perform
the baseline method,
which is the weighted sum
of the tokens,
and this one also didn't
perform very well.
So, the conclusion is that
the dependency information
is very important
in this task because we
don't have a lot of data,
and some external knowledge
from the dependency parser
is very important.
Also, the baseline method
decrease the performance.
We think this is because
it introduce some
redundant parameters.
We also find out that replace the
[inaudible] representation we
selected between
the concept layer
would significantly
improve their performance,
which can give us
the best result of 44.1.
So, the summary of this research
is that we introduce
a new neural relation
extraction model
to scientific domain,
and we propose a novel
Concept Selection Layer to
the neural structure that
can leverage unlabeled data.
Also, we obtain
the state-of-the-art result in
SemEval 2018 Task seven.
So that's it. Any questions?
>> I have one question.
You mentioned about, if
you go to the experiment,
so you mentioned the Team
One having a better result
and you mentioned that they used
more unlabeled or labeled data?
>> Labeled data.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. So, there are
separate datasets
for different tasks,
and they are
combining those data.
>> I see, because you're showing
that unlabeled data
actually really helps,
so I was just under
the impression that-
>> Yeah, they are using
more supervised data there.
>> Got it.
Okay. Is there
any other question?
Okay.
Thank you.